hola que tal buenos dias evidentemente
en bolivia rige una veda electoral entre
hoy jueves y el domingo y por tanto se
percibe una calma en las diferentes
ciudades del país sin embargo debo
comentarles que el alto comisionado de
naciones unidas para los derechos
humanos ha detectado más de 40 episodios
de violencia en la campaña electoral en
bolivia desde septiembre hasta la fecha
y eso se debe a que los partidos
políticos por ejemplo se han agredido
entre sí han quemado sus casas de
campaña no ha sido violencia que ha
llegado a hechos mayores pero que sí ha
generado un ambiente de malestar en el
país por otro lado les comento que las
últimas horas la ciudadanía sobre todo
en la paz está haciendo largas filas en
los surtidores de gasolina para llegar a
llenar los tanques de los vehículos y
además está recurriendo a los centros de
abasto para comprar muchos alimentos
pues existe el temor de que después de
las elecciones hubiera algún partido que
no quiera reconocer los resultados y se
pueda generar violencia en ese marco los
organismos internacionales que están
observando las elecciones han pedido a
los partidos que reconozcan los
resultados y que garanticen la
en bolivia cómo está el proceso de
transparencia electoral mary quienes
estarán vigilando los comicios estas van
a ser unas elecciones muy observadas tal
vez las más observadas de la historia de
bolivia después del presunto fraude que
se ha cometido el año pasado existen por
ejemplo misiones de observación de la
organización de estados américanos que
ha acreditado a 40 expertos de
diferentes nacionalidades está la unión
europea está también el centro cárter y
como nunca se ha establecido una red
enorme de ciudadanos que van a observar
las elecciones por ejemplo existe una
iniciativa que se llama bolivia observa
y que aglutina a 2.500 ciudadanos que
van a estar mirando la transparencia de
este proceso muy bien meriva acá muchas
gracias por tu reporte la corresponsal
de france 24 en bolivia